yes thank you all for getting up this
early how many know John Miller the guy
that runs our journalism program okay
don't tell him this but John and I are
in a contest where every month you have
to pay the other guy a dollar if they're
ahead of you in Twitter accounts so if
you would follow me on Twitter and if
you're following John if you could just
unfollow them that would be great now at
the end of this session we're going to
know more about bitcoins and probably
ninety eight percent of all Americans
that two percent either has pocket
protectors or they have a seaplane that
takes them to Martha's Vineyard for the
weekend true the authors are going to
tell us a little bit about whether
bitcoin is money or will it become money
and what what money is in the and the
other is going to tell us the mechanics
basically of how it works and I was just
thinking that that Hayek would be fairly
intrigued with the idea of bitcoins in
1976 he wrote a little book called the D
nationalization of money in which he
called for private monies and said we
don't need central banks to do this and
and the primary reason is he felt that
central banking was the cause for
business cycles that central banks
interfered with the price system in the
following way and I if you again I
needed told you about our online courses
if you get on the econ 101 online course
and you look for lecture 9 an Austrian
business cycle theory I might help out
although this but but basically if
you're an entrepreneur you need to know
whether to make the hot dogs or make the
machine that makes the hot dogs and so
you have the then allocate resources not
only across products but over time so
how do you get a signal that says I need
to make the machine instead of the hot
dog because people are trying to save
now and they're going to want to buy hot
dogs in the future and the answer is the
interest rate when interest rates are
low I'm knowing that people are saving
and so I should start making the
machines that made hot dogs if the
interest rates are high I said okay
these characters aren't saving very much
it should make the hot dogs now the
problem that Hayek saw was that central
banks come in and by increasing a
decrease in the money supply affect the
supply of loanable funds and therefore
affect the interest rates and so what
you get is the either the wrong signal
or you don't know what the signal is and
if you get the wrong signal then you do
things like you build lots of houses for
which there's really no demand not that
that might happen but if you and so what
what Hayek said was you know the way to
solve this problem is to not have the
central banks have money but rather have
private currencies and so that's what
we're going to look at today I'm sure he
would he would be very interested in and
the bitcoins and other private
currencies that are taking place here
and historically we find that there's
been private currencies for a long time
so what I'd like to do is I'd like to
start out with introducing Garrick
Heilman Derek is expert on bitcoins and
other currencies and he in fact he had a
read his paper and it's a very nice
paper he makes regular appearances on
television and he writes for numerous
publications he's the founder of macro
digest which looks at economic news
analysis and debate before returning to
a kadeem derek work for more than 15
years in the private sector in both
equity research and corporate finance
which is I can tell you if you go out
into the real world and come back to the
classroom it really makes a difference
currently he's teaching at the London
School of Economics and finished his PhD
in economic history and he's going to be
speaking on the history of alternative
currency so that let's have a hand for
Garrick
thank you Gary it's a pleasure to be
here I'm going to move a little quickly
through quite a bit of material here
because we only have 20 minutes and to
have a really rich discussion about
Bitcoin it's important I think to cover
quite a bit of ground so let's just get
right started first it's important that
we have a good basis of understanding
about money and currency so we're going
to go through some some basics there
talk about alternative currencies what
those are spend a little time talking
about Bitcoin not so much how it works
which is going to be covered a little
bit later but about the Bitcoin economy
and then talk about what history might
have to say about bitcoins use as a
currency this is an important point here
to make Bitcoin has many potential uses
one of which is a currency others
include being a technology platform but
this presentation is primarily focused
on Bitcoin as currency or money okay so
let's get started so money in currency
how many here in this room were taught
in high school the answer to this
question show hands where does money
come from I saw about two or three hands
go up this is something that is
incredibly important to everyone's
everyday life and yet it's not taught in
high school somehow remarkably now most
people think that money comes from the
government and the banknotes and the
coins that are in your pocket of course
are printed by the government or the Fed
or the mint but the vast majority of
money actually comes from banks it is
private money it's privately produced by
banks and lent into existence through
new loans over ninety percent of money
prior to quantitative easing at least
comes from banks somebody may have
changed their with quantitative easing
that's a really important point though
to understand you know where money
basically comes from and and I would
encourage all of you to actually go out
and be ambassadors for further educating
the population on where money comes from
that it's lent into existence so money
has three core functions these are the
textbook definitions it's a medium
exchange it solves this double
coincidence of wants problem where I've
got a horse you've got a cow we want to
do business but I don't want your cow
it's a store value it's something that
retains its value from day to day and
it's also a unit of account which
means it's what goods and services are
priced in those are the three things
that money does money has a hierarchy so
these three functions are not all equal
in terms of their importance to defining
what money is many things or stores of
value house is a store value fewer
things are a medium of exchange media
exchange means that two people have to
agree on what we're going to use is a
store value at least temporarily to
trade and the highest point in the
hierarchy is the unit of account this is
a medium exchange that's use across time
and place between several people and
therefore represents a coordination
across society this is a really
important point here about the unit of
account function of money economists
believe generally that this function of
money is its most important function
therefore and this is kind of a visual
depiction of the hierarchy of money many
things can be a store value fewer our
medium exchange and very very few things
become a unit of account the thing in
which goods and services are priced in
and more importantly perhaps even how we
even think about money so we don't think
in terms of Bitcoin prices today not
that many things or price in bitcoins we
think in terms of dollars in euros and
pounds and we hate doing currency
conversions when we travel abroad I
don't know if you're like me it's really
annoying so there's a an issue there
we'll come back to a little bit later so
money and currency is there a difference
in my paper I spent a lot of time
talking about this i would suggest and
this is argumentative but i would
suggest that we should distinguish
between money and currency money has all
three of those functions including the
univ account so all money is also
currency but i would say that not all
currency is money currency can be just a
medium of exchange but not a unit of
account you now may set up a temporary
meeting of exchange but it's not widely
accepted and therefore it should not be
thought of as money it should be thought
of as just a currency and under that
definition we can answer our question
that often comes up is Bitcoin money no
it's a currency it's not money though
because it's not a widely used unit of
account across time and space yet so in
my paper i defined five different
currency types
is really to kind of overarching
categories you have your legal tender so
things like national dollars like the US
dollar you have adopted currencies so
Ecuador in Panama actually use the US
dollar for example as their national
currency it's been adopted and it's
legal to do that you have parallel
currencies so prior to the introduction
of the euro you know countries like
Portugal Italy other eurozone members
they ran their national currencies the
lira the excluder alongside the euro in
parallel these are all examples of legal
tender currencies currencies which we
use to settle debts to pay taxes with
there are two types of non legal tender
currencies black market currencies those
that are illegal and interestingly
occurrence you like the US dollar which
is legal in the United States is illegal
in a place like Argentina so can
actually wear two hats at the same time
and then you have alternative currencies
which is what we're here to talk about
today so what is an alternative currency
so when I first started doing research
in this space I was hit with a alphabet
soup of terms to describe alternative
currencies and here is just a few of
them local currency complementary
currency parallel currency is also used
with alternative currency black market
commodity script token currencies
digital currencies virtual currencies
crypto currencies you've got regulators
today which are calling Bitcoin here in
the United States a virtual currency
that's the term used by the Treasury the
New York Department of Financial
Services over in England where I teach
digital currency is the term that's used
for you know by the Bank of England you
had a lot of money is actually digital
so this is all very confusing I spend a
lot of time in the paper actually trying
to sort out the definitions in terms and
I propose a framework for how we should
define this but first what is an
alternative currency my definition is
that it's any instrument which legally
operates so it's legal to use as a
medium of exchange but is not minted by
the central government or officially
recognized as legal tender that's my
definition and if we look at the
different types of alternative
currencies and again I cover this in the
paper there are two types are digital
and there are tangible first let's talk
about the tangible ones come in two
forms ones that have intrinsic you
they're useful in and of themselves the
cigarette you can see I have up there as
an example of both the historical and
contemporary I don't know if any of you
watch oranges new black you'll the
cigarette is probably one of the more
durable alternative currencies
throughout history it's was used in poww
camps and Berlin after World War Two
it's used today sim cards with airtime
minutes or actually used as currency in
parts of Africa those are things that
have you know usefulness in and of their
own right metals of course if we go
further back could be thought of as an
intrinsic currency things that are
commodity money tokens are more
conceptual they rely on you know social
agreements so you know in the UK there
were merchant tokens from the 16th
through 18th century that were used by
merchants who are dealing with this
problem called the big problem of small
change was very expensive to meant lots
of currency small denomination currency
so merchants started issuing their own
currencies today you know you have
currencies like in Massachusetts the
BerkShares you may be familiar with that
in London the bricks can pound these are
little local currencies that communities
have gotten together to issue to really
try to keep commerce local and also
attack concerns about the globalization
and the environment and whatnot so on
the Digital side which we're going to
talk mostly about today you've got you
know these different currency types and
you can really think about them across
this this matrix here of centralized and
decentralized digital currencies that
are operating in either a closed an open
system so the classic kind of modern
closed centralized digital currency is
from Second Life this virtual reality
world which was was very widely talked
about about a decade ago the Linden
dollar was printed by a central
organization Linden Labs and it operated
inside a closed environment inside the
Second Life virtual reality world about
15 years ago there were a number of
startups in Silicon Valley launching
digital currencies like flus and beans
anyone remember those now the the VCS
who were backing Bitcoin today along
don't like to talk about
and beans we'll talk more about why in a
minute but those were open you could use
them at a variety of places they weren't
bounded but they still had a central
issuer bitcoin is arguably the first
open and decentralized digital currency
meaning that it can be pretty much used
anywhere and there is no central point
of issuance a single note that can be
shut down we'll go over that more detail
in the next presentations so looking at
the 500 years of history of alternative
currencies that I that and I think they
you know the history goes back even
further still there's some common themes
that actually pop up in terms of why
these things tend to proliferate over
time and all seven of these themes I
found historical precedent for except
the one at the top environmentalism
that's a relatively new theme that seems
to be driving a lot of alternative
currency growth but improvements in
technology you know localism even during
the Great Depression there were concerns
about out of town retailers that was a
big part of why so many script
currencies were introduced in the 1930s
concerns about inefficiency financial
repression which is capital controls
restrictions on the financial system and
then the political economy categories a
bit of a catch-all things for everything
from high levels of debt to unemployment
concerns etc those are the forces which
are driving interest in alternative
currencies okay so Bitcoin so I'm going
to focus mostly kind of on the
high-level overview of the Bitcoin
economy and kind of what's going on here
why are we talking about Bitcoin it's a
good question why are we even talking
about Bitcoin to begin with I think
there's three big reasons we're talking
about Bitcoin so first bitcoin is
unquestionably innovative as we'll hear
more about later there's a real
innovation which took place here second
I don't know any other asset class in
history that had as big an annual
appreciation as Bitcoin did in 2013 of
56 x ok the media loves this story my
first invitation to come on television
was you know the proverbial has the
bubble burst after the Cyprus incident
last year and you know the price
collapsed but the media is fascinated by
the
this is price story tulips went up I
think 26x just to put this in comparison
and Holland so big big brought up a
price and finally reason number three is
this guy the inventor or person or woman
we don't know who this is we'll probably
hear more about not only did this person
demonstrate a real genius for for
cryptography and software development
but this person was a genius at
marketing because Satoshi has managed to
the inventor of Bitcoin has managed to
keep his her whoever this is their
identity completely secret and so
there's a mystery here at the heart of
Bitcoin who is the founder and this is
captivated the media's attention all
three these things have media is how we
come to know things right that's why
we're talking about Bitcoin and those
are the three big reasons its innovative
the price and the mystery at the heart
of the creation of Bitcoin so Bitcoin
you know there's a lot of drama also
surrounding Bitcoin to a lot of bad news
various people arrested black markets
all this exotic trade going on but it's
not all bad news you've got Ben Bernanke
famously an autumn of last year coming
down saying that the coin may hold
promise you know a list entrepreneurs
like Richard Branson agreeing to accept
it it's being used in places like
Argentina to to achieve social
objectives with farming so mix of bad
good news but the media has really
latched onto this that's why we're
talking about Bitcoin it's it's really
captured the zeitgeist I've got a trio
har vard Ian's here I don't know if
that's a word or not including my my
thesis advisor Neil Ferguson who I
convinced that he initially thought
Bitcoin was just a speculative object
but he said some more positive things i
think more recently but others like Ken
Rogoff you know it's not occurrence he
is not going to become one still a lot
of skeptics you know in the in the in
the you know the public intellectual
space but they're talking about bitcoins
really captured people's imaginations so
the venture capital community thinks
that bitcoins as big as the PC or the
internet Marc Andreessen wrote a really
interesting piece in The New York Times
earlier this year making this argument
he thinks Bitcoin today is that where
the internet was in 1993 and the pc was
in 1975 if you look at the amount of
money there
investing the VCS are in Bitcoin
startups it's pretty significant 375
million of publicly disclosed money to
date so the real number is probably well
north of 400 million and if you compare
that to what they were investing in the
internet back in nineteen ninety five
which is the earliest year we have data
they put 250 million dollars into
internet startups in 1995 this is not
inflation-adjusted number two all sorts
of other adjustments you might want to
make true a true apples-to-apples
comparison such as you know the lowering
cost of watching a start-up etc etc but
it's still interesting that in 2014 this
year that mark compares to 1993 we're
projecting to well exceed what was
invested in the internet in Bitcoin
startups so the VCS are walking the talk
this is a big deal you know there's all
sorts of things that potentially Bitcoin
could disrupt in terms of the financial
services system payment processing
deposit fees withdrawal and overdraft
fees foreign exchange fees float charges
transfer wire fees title insurance
copyright registration this is getting
more into kind of the other uses of
Bitcoin beyond currency you could use
Bitcoin as a notary service escrow
collections so big opportunities here
this is a depiction of the Bitcoin
economy in terms of the companies that
are operating in the Bitcoin space
there's six different kind of categories
of companies you've got wallets this is
where you store your Bitcoin you've got
exchanges where you can go to buy them
you've got payment processors these are
the companies that plug in to some of
the retailers which are accepting
Bitcoin and make it easy for those
retailers to avoid any Forex risk to
accept Bitcoin but then instantly
convert into dollars and they pay these
processors fees sometimes for that there
is mining companies will talk next
presentation more about mining but these
are the companies that are producing the
hardware which runs the Bitcoin network
and then there's a catch-all group
called financial services for everything
from Bitcoin ATMs could Bitcoin gift
cards to news organizations but in the
center there I have a category called
universal and those of you who are
familiar with the banking system might
recognize this term the universal
Bitcoin companies are the ones that are
kind of
looking to operate in multiple kind of
parts of the value chain here they're
providing exchange services wallet
financial services etc they're
leveraging to kind of key deficiencies
right now with with Bitcoin in any
financial services system which is trust
so if I trust you as a wallet I'll more
likely to trust you as an exchange and
also efficiency same thing we see with
banking right and and the universals are
collecting you know more money than most
they have a twenty-two percent of the
total vc investment that's gone into
this ecosystem to date but you see
that's roughly well balanced across the
different six sectors in terms of where
the money is going there's about six
million Bitcoin wallets today so that's
you know an approximate size for how
many people are actually using Bitcoin
although there's no restriction on you
having multiple wallets so that's you
know take that with a grain of salt and
that's not even a complete estimate but
we know there's roughly about that and
I'm projecting about eight million by
the end of the year so that's that's
kind of the growth trajectory over
75,000 merchants which which are
currently accepting Bitcoin including
some big names Dell not long ago
announced they're accepting Bitcoin they
do about 60 billion in revenue a year
they're offering actually offering ten
percent off alienware products so if
you're you know your your little one is
a gamer and you want to save a little
money send them to dell site michael
dell can pay me a little late for that
little free plug right but a lot of big
merchants are getting behind this
there's a PR benefit to 22 saying you
accept Bitcoin the news media covers
that and some companies are actually
doing significant revenues overstock i
think is projecting they're going to do
about a million dollars a month by the
end of this year so commerce is starting
to take off still very small though so
let's talk about price though because
that's what's in the news bitcoins price
has been plummeting since the beginning
of the year it rallied a little bit in
the second quarter but then it dropped
about forty percent the last quarter and
then drop further still what's going on
with that well there's a lot of people
who who have a lot of reasons you know a
lot of ideas about what's going on with
price you know some of the early
adopters are selling
the there's a general correction and
technology equity strong US dollar
concerns about what's called a
51-percent attack which we'll get into
I'm sure later global instability
competition from Apple pay etc I think
the real reason the price has been
suffering is is related to this chart
here so Bitcoin to earn bitcoins you
have to process a you have to you have
to compute a puzzle basically with your
computer you and I can go download the
Bitcoin software and start mining new
bitcoins or try to but that's getting
harder and harder so there's an arms
race going on basically and the people
who are mining bitcoins have to spend
more and more money on new faster
computers to do it and those computers
have to be paid for along with the
electricity to run them sometimes it was
something other than Bitcoin so some of
the new bitcoins are coming on market
have to be sold in the marketplace and
that's what's driving it take the price
down okay so let's quickly go through
this new piece of research i'm working
on called the Bitcoin market potential
index this is a index which is meant
answer the question of where Bitcoin
might get traction what factors might
drive growth in Bitcoin first i'll give
you the rankings these are the top 10
countries where bitcoin has the most
potential utility Argentina's number one
basically things like you know how big
is the international remittances market
what's the level of technology
penetration how much Bitcoin penetration
is how many people are using the
software are kind of the positive index
drivers the more negative index drivers
or how much inflation or is in the
country financial repression you know
what's the history of financial crises
how big is the black market those things
drive the rankings and you can see Latin
America in general is number one they've
got forty percent of the top 10
countries in about twenty-seven percent
of the top 30 followed by Africa and
post-soviet areas so important for us
here in the first four world first world
to understand that Bitcoin as a currency
has I think much greater utility outside
of places like the United States which
has four old warts and all you know a
reasonably stable currency and
reasonably well run financial system
relative to the rest of the world so
Bitcoin could help people potentially
leapfrog credit cards in banking Cal
in the same way that people in Africa
kind of you know leapfrogged landlines
and went right to mobile phones those
are prepaid you don't need a credit
history to get a mobile phone you just
bring in your cash same thing with with
bank accounts you know you had to have a
history there so so this is an
opportunity if you want to see an
interactive heat map of the market
potential index you can go to Bitcoin IQ
dot info okay I've got to move here
really quickly through the rest of this
here so what can history tell us about
Bitcoin well we know who won the last
battle and trying to make money more
plentiful versus more scarce in the late
19th century in the the duel you know
the battle over the gold standard and
adding silver New York one they beat the
farmers out west and William Jennings
Bryan and gold remained the standard
silver was not added you can see a
similar battle playing out here today
with the bankers in New York you know
Jamie Dimon and others not a big fan of
this silicon valley out west pushing for
money to become more plentiful we'll see
who wins this time but history is not
necessarily all that encouraging three
ways in which alternative currencies die
primarily they die a quick death by the
way that's the big headline for my
research they don't last very long by
and large regulation is not a leading
cause but it has happened the free geld
and the Great Depression was outlawed by
the Australian Central Bank Bitcoin
hasn't been banned in that many places
yet though so I don't think regulation
right now is a big risk to Bitcoin but
you are seeing companies move from say
New York to London in response to us
regulatory pressure another leading
cause of alternative currency death is
technology I think this is a much bigger
threat to bitcoin and bitcoin is quite
ironic is trying to do with paper do
away with paper money and banks but the
same time the safest way to secure your
bitcoins to actually print them out on a
paper wallet is this call and actually
keep it in a safe deposit box hmm you
know we don't have time to cover that
will cover I'm sure later the biggest
cause for alternative currency death is
simply lack of adoption these things
just you know cease to be desired that
kills by and large almost all these
things why would something not get
adopted well charts like this this this
is a one of the early charts used to
explain what bitcoin is try showing this
to your you know
average person in the street and their
eyes are going to glaze over social
movements are very hard to maintain
there's very much a movement around
Bitcoin can that be sustained they don't
always last very long and we've tried
this before vc's invested hundreds of
millions in these previous digital
currencies and they didn't work there's
also a very highly concentrated
ownership structure of Bitcoin one
person sorry half the bitcoins are held
by oh just a thousand people so very
very tightly you know controlled
currency supply so final thoughts real
quick very hard to forecast for bitcoins
going it's it's this complex
intersection between technology policy
and economics these things are
constantly changing and shifting you
know bitcoins fate is really linked to
the global financial stability or
instability as well I mean how
successful are the world central bank's
going to be it continuing to hold hands
as they do and jump off the cliff
together in keeping the whole ship
afloat that's going to have an impact on
you know bitcoins future yeah we'll just
skip through these it's not unreasonable
for me though to imagine the day like
Barry I kumakain Duns when the US dollar
is no longer going to be the dominant
reserve currency and there's a
rebalancing and should there be enough
global instability something like
Bitcoin being introduced as a new you
know as part of a new basket of reserve
currencies say as a ree you know
recalibrating of the IMF Special Drawing
rights i think that is conceivable
especially if things go badly the more
optimistic view about bitcoin is that
we're you know looking at the technology
height cycle we're down here in the
trough a more pessimistic view about
bitcoin as a currency is that how can it
ever become money if it's volatile and
without a central bank standing behind
it to set a ceiling and a floor on the
value the exchange rate of bitcoin it's
always going to be more volatile than a
well-run national currency that has a
central bank with unlimited fire power
effectively to back that currency that's
going to be that's going to be a really
hard hurdle for Bitcoin to clear in
terms of becoming a unit account so
that's all thank you for give me a
little extra time
alright sir one third of the way of
knowing more than anybody else in this
Sam powder swimming next and he's the
senior policy analyst at the Koch
Institute he's the author of one of the
first books on explaining how bitcoins
work called Bitcoin beginner he's
written for several pro liberty
organizations on bitcoins and he's
involved in open source projects which I
told him I wasn't quite sure what that
meant that this morning that the aim to
decentralize the existing networks in
order to give individuals more Liberty
and more freedom over what they do and
and how to control their own money and
trade you can read his articles at crony
crony chronicles org so with that Sam
Patterson thank you very much so um see
whoops we get my slides up here we have
these this is what happens when you rely
on technology you know I just use a
blackboard and white chalk I'm good to
go
so this is a technically complex subject
so teaching you know trying to explain
it in 20 minutes it's like drinking from
a fire hose okay so you may not get
everything I'm going to go through here
and that's okay the goal is just to
learn more about it and to get a general
sort of overview of how it works
technically so before I go into the
technical details and we get the slide
up i'm going to give you a story about a
way to think about bitcoin which is
meant to be non-technical so and if you
guys don't have the you don't have the
slide show i have it on the USB drive
here if that would help
always carry a USB backup okay so a
group of 12 Islanders on remote island
in the middle of Pacific all right
there's a group of these these guys out
in the middle of nowhere they deeply
distrust each other each blaming the
other for the boating accident that left
them stranded here months ago they all
decide to live on separate parts of the
island but soon discover that they need
the skills and work of others to survive
and thrive over the months a form of
currency arises on the island cowrie
shells which cannot be faked these were
historically used as a currency long
time ago and they begin trading at each
other until one accuses the other of
stealing thank you some of these shells
during a trade the villagers talk about
creating a bank to hold the shells for
them but no one trusts anyone else to
run that bank so they decide to arrange
a system that will prevent theft without
a bank they make a small clearing the
middle of the island and place 12
unbreakable glass boxes in the clearing
each with the individuals name on it
they have a slit at the top where you
can deposit shells into but they cannot
be opened without a key which each
villager has to their own box they all
deposit their shells into their boxes
record the number of shells in everyone
else's boxes and their own and they
review the numbers with each other to
make sure everyone agrees now the
villagers engaged in trade by visiting
the clearing taking shells from their
own box and depositing it in another
villagers box they then change the
numbers in a public ledger which is
posted in the middle of the clearing and
everyone can see the number of shells in
the boxes and all parties can review
this public ledger to make sure that it
is accurate years pass the next
generation of Islanders has added more
boxes as the village grew one young
bright villager was watching the active
trade in the clearing one day
and came to the realization that the
public ledger itself was representing
the trade because the shells had no real
value and as long as the villagers
agreed to the changes in the ledger the
boxes and shells didn't need to exist
but the villagers were still mistrustful
of each other so they determined that
using unfortunate shares at the time of
the transaction they could actually all
meet at the end of the day and update
this public ledger in the clearing
together if someone had tried to cheat
someone during the day this fraud would
be exposed and the reckoning of the
ledger at night many generations later
the island became technologically
advanced with networked computers an
enterprising young villager realized
that instead of maintaining this massive
public ledger in the clearing and
updating at every night it could be made
digital distributed to all the villagers
on their computers and updated over the
network in real-time as soon as the
ledger changed between two villagers
there's a transaction everyone knew what
the trade was and because they had a
history of all the transactions in this
ledger they could verify if those
amounts were accurate as you may have
guessed this is basically Bitcoin it's a
distributed public ledger that allows
for trading digital currency with
another party without needing to trust
them because the entire network is
verifying that new transactions are
valid continuously ok that's the non
technical explanation so what is Bitcoin
I know there's a rule you're not
supposed to read from your slides I'm
going to make an exception for the
abstract of my paper I'm going to talk
through this year so bitcoin is a
technological and monetary innovation
that allows for peer-to-peer transfer
value without trusting third parties the
system uses a distributed public ledger
to reach consensus among Network
participants the users of the currency
about the legitimacy of transactions the
ledger is not to nominate with fiat
currencies but instead uses its own
units called bit
the system relies on various elements of
cryptography which is basically fancy
math to ensure that this public ledger
is accurate instead of relying on a
central institution the code is open
source which basically means everyone
can look at it review it and contribute
to it and the network is decentralized
resulting in low barriers to entry and
censorship resistance anyone can join
the network and use it and it's very
difficult essentially impossible to shut
down from an outside party because it's
just people running the programs on
their computers all over the world new
bitcoins are issued by a predictable
algorithm that is intended to replicate
the mining of a scarce resource I'll
talk about that in a minute okay so what
is Bitcoin really okay it's actually two
things Bitcoin in bitcoins Bitcoin
uppercase singular is a network for this
tray that we talked about bitcoins are
the digital currency that this network
uses ok most people talk about bitcoins
it's a digital currency and garrick did
an excellent job of doing so but it's
actually the network where the
innovation takes place and this is
because it solves a double spending
problem so bitcoins are not the first
digital currency all right we had
previous ones but they were all
centralized to avoid double spending
double spending is what it sounds like
if you have a digital currency how can
you be sure that your digital
representation of value hasn't been
duplicated and spent elsewhere it's very
easy to copy a file right you can send
the same piece of data a hundred times
in the past they solve this by having a
central institution that maintained that
ledger okay if you sent ten units of the
digital currency from your account
someone else this company would take the
central institution would take 10 out of
yours put 10 into theirs it equal to 0
the end the day that's how they solve
the double spending problem Bitcoin
solves the double spending problem
without relying on a central institution
because the ledger of transactions is
public and distributed to all
participants and there are cryptographic
rules that ensure it must be legitimate
moving forward so the distributed ledger
which is called the blockchain talk
about that in a minute contains the
history of
every transaction which has ever
occurred on the network allowing any
participant to know the exact ledger
balances at any moment and importantly
verify if proposed transactions are
legitimate if someone tries to double
spend the network will look at it and
say wait a minute that bitcoin was
already here and it's gone here this is
an invalid transaction will be rejected
bitcoin is based on cryptography okay
which is just a way of saying using math
to secure communications and identities
the network and the currency aren't
managed by rule of law or by rule of man
but are ruled by math just a unique way
to have a currency it uses public key
cryptography for the digital signatures
and cryptographic hashing for proof of
work I know probably unfamiliar with
those terms I'll go through those
quickly public key cryptography uses a
key pair for secure communication
identity a key pair is a public key
which is a random string of letters and
numbers and a private key which is a
random string of letters and numbers
that correlates corresponds to the
public key they're linked so what you
need to know is this is Bob trying to
send a message to Alice Alice has a key
pair of public key and a private key
everyone can see your public key and Bob
takes the message hello Alice encrypts
it just means use math in a fancy way
with Alice's public key it sent Alice
only she is able to decrypt it with her
private key and read that message this
also works for signatures if Alice were
to sign a message with her private key
then people can verify by looking at the
public key that this was actually her
that signed it that's our digital
signatures work so how would using
bitcoin is we talked about this
distributed ledger right this this
history of transactions which which
everyone can look at and the bitcoins
are in this ledger right but how do you
how is ownership defined of entries in
this ledger right how is ownership a
Bitcoin to find well the public key in
this pair is used to create a Bitcoin
address
where the funds reside everyone can see
this address in the network it's made
with a public key but the private key
which only the individual has controls
the fund themselves they actually have
access to the transaction so it uses
public key cryptography to verify this
basically so in order for Network
participants which are commonly referred
to as nodes to determine that a user is
legitimately in control over a certain
entry in the public ledger over a
certain portion of bitcoins the node
which initiates a transaction when they
try to send money will sign a message
with their private key stating they want
to send bitcoins from their public
address to another public address and
that is broadcast to the network so once
this message is distributed other nodes
verify that the signature matches the
public key of the address if it's valid
if it does match up then it's put into a
queue essentially of transactions called
a block which I'll talk about a second
it's not valid it's rejected and it
never makes it into the block so a block
contains all the transactions that have
been proposed on this network
essentially since the last block was
added and new blocks are added about
every ten minutes headed to what okay
added to the blockchain added to the
public record of transactions so the
blockchain is a chronological chain of
blocks hence the name that extends
backward to the first transaction on the
network back in January 2009 by Satoshi
Nakamoto the individual who created this
currency and importantly every user has
the same blockchain to check against
they all had the identical public ledger
the blockchain to make sure new
transactions are valid right now is
about 326,000 blocks that have been
created so far how are these created
well there's cryptographic rules about
how new blocks are created and added to
this block chain if not for these rules
it would be difficult for Network
participants users of the currency to
agree to a shared version of the BOK
chain right if someone's adding
something to block chain one way and
someone's doing a different way those
block chains are now different and
you cannot use it as a shared ledger for
exchanging currency so you use something
called proof of work proof of work
basically just means creating a block is
difficult it takes a lot of time to do
as I said approximately 10 minutes and
this is done by cryptographic hashing
I'm not going to go into the details of
that it basically just means you take an
arbitrary piece of data you put it
through an algorithm that changes it and
puts out another arbitrary piece of data
so what happens is in order for an ode
to broadcast a block right they've
collected all the transactions they want
to push this block into the blockchain
into this permanent record they must
broadcast proof that they did an
extensive hashing necessary a lot of
work to find the solution to an
arbitrary puzzle all these nodes are
attempting to add a block to the
blockchain simultaneously by hashing
sha-256 that's just an algorithm and
search for an output that begins with a
certain number of zeros that just it
just means you're finding a puzzle to a
problem a an answer to a puzzle so the
first node to find that answer which is
random broadcasts that block along with
the answer to all the other nodes and if
it's accurate it's added to that block
chain the difficulty of this adjusts
automatically if you have more people on
the network it's harder to find the
answer but it still takes about 10
minutes and the node which solves the
puzzle is rewarded with bitcoins right
now the block reward is about 25
bitcoins for finding one of these blocks
and adding it to the blockchain used to
be 50 every four years it goes in half
so in two years from now it'll be 12 and
a half etc until eventually we reach a
limit of 21 million bitcoins that will
ever be mine so there is actually a cap
to the money supply in Bitcoin it can
never exceed 20 1,000,000 the network
itself is reliant on code which is open
source and decentralized as i mentioned
open source just means everyone can look
at it everyone can review what everyone
can propose changes that means it has
low barriers to entry and censorship
resistance as I mentioned the code is
not stagnant it can change with
consensus if people have an improvement
to add to this digital crud
work and currency they can propose it
and if other people agree to it then
they becomes de facto the network size
is unknown there are at least hundreds
of thousands of users you heard eight
million wallets earlier there's probably
not eight million users because you can
use more than one wallet but we don't
know how many users there are Bitcoin
improvement protocols proposals are
additions to the existing code some are
adopted in some aren't and there's some
notable ones that i'll go through really
quickly multi signature is just really
fascinating it's a way to use currency
that just has not existed before
basically instead of one person owning
this private key and having access to
these bitcoins you break that up and
multiple people have sort of joint
ownership and a certain portion of those
people have to agree before a
transaction can happen the most popular
one right now is called two of three
multi signature which means two of three
people must both digitally sign a
transaction before it'll be legitimate
in the record this allows for things
like escrow we have a buyer a seller and
a an arbiter or someone in escrow and
two of those three people must agree
before the transaction happens that will
prevent scamming online right the buyer
and seller will have to agree for the
two of three or if one's trying to scan
the other the third party and the buyer
with a third part in the seller will
agree to change the where the Bitcoin
end up hierarchical deterministic
wallets this is just a way of saying
instead of having a new private key pair
for each of these Bitcoin addresses we
have one master key pair that allows you
to create a whole bunch of new ones
using the same key passwords for private
keys and merchant protocols there's a
lot of these so while it's themselves or
how you store the Bitcoin so the private
key as I mentioned is essentially
ownership over the Bitcoin in themselves
without the private key you cannot
access the funds in this block chain so
owning a Bitcoin means owning the
private key while it's store private
keys some are more secure someone more
convenient I have a lot on my smartphone
not particularly secure but is very
convenient
but all them have different features but
there's some core functionality of wall
it's how they work one is that they hold
users private keys naturally one is that
they sign and broadcast transactions
with the private key that's actually
being able to send the Bitcoin and the
last is that they monitor the blockchain
to keep funds updated if there's
transactions coming to you you want to
be able to see that naturally so those
are the core functions of wallets
altcoins would take too much time to
explain so basically just avoid them
essentially there they are what they are
is a Bitcoin clone with small
adjustments to the code for the most
part people take the Bitcoin code they
change a few lines here they release it
with a new name sometimes it's just a
joke sometimes it's a scam so I wouldn't
get involved with them basically but it
is important to know that block chains
aren't only good for transferring
digital currency they can do all kinds
of stuff one's called namecoin that
allows for a distributed identity system
instead of relying on the existing
identity systems you can have it in a
blockchain and also Bitcoin itself is
not only used to transfer digital
currency the Bitcoin blockchain is also
can be used as an asset register you can
basically take a small amount of Bitcoin
say this represents the deed to a house
or this represents a share an X company
and when you transfer that Bitcoin
because it's all in the public ledger
you're essentially transferring
ownership it's pretty fascinating stuff
ok so in conclusion their bitcoins a
distributed public ledger for
transferring digital currency without
trusting in third parties it has a large
and growing network and this is probably
why so many people in the Liberty
movement if you want to call it that
people who are supportive of free
markets are excited it's reliant on math
instead of relying on central bank's
instead of being reliant on traditional
banks or on payment processors or on the
government agencies which regulate and
control these industries so tightly and
prevent innovation from occurring thank
you
well now we snow two-thirds more than
anybody else now I'd like to introduce
our last speaker George salgan Jimmy
George's professor of economics emeritus
at the University of Georgia and he's
now director of I think it's a new
Institute is that right yeah yeah yeahs
the nooks center Cato says Institute
Center for monetary and financial
alternatives he's author of several
books he's well-known in the history of
money and monetary theory including good
money Birmingham button makers the Royal
Mint and the beginnings of modern
coinage which was published in 2008 it's
also editor of a co-editor of economic
journal watch which is an electronic
journal I've looked at it several times
myself I'm devoted to exposing quote
inappropriate assumptions week chains of
argument phony claims of relevance and
omissions of pertinent truths in the
writings of professional economists
which means it's a very thick journal
with that I'd like to introduce George
saljem thank you all thanks Gary anita
asked me to give a talk on bitcoin she
did that and it originally asked me to
give a talk about the problems of
Bitcoin but i personally think bitcoins
a wonderful thing although I admit it in
part that's because it's now not
possible for people to claim that
monetary economics is the most
needlessly obscure an impenetrable
subject on the planet but in fact I
really did want to say some positive
things as well as pointing out some
problems about Bitcoin and that's what
I'm going to do today as as Sams talk
made clear and and Sam really did do a
good job producing some of that
impenetrability I refer to bitcoins are
our digital our digital medium they're
not actual coins so you must get out of
your minds is this image of
metallic disc although there are such
things out there that are actually I
think a form of Bitcoin wallet more than
anything else and I'm relieved not to
have to summarize how Bitcoin works
although I was going to do so using that
chart if we actually I found it shard
impossible myself and put it up for the
same reason so let's start out with the
first problem about Bitcoin which is one
that that Garrick I think already
presented to us which is a simple fact
that by most definitions they aren't
money Garrick emphasized the unit of
account I tend to emphasize the medium
of exchange function it's really not
important frankly which one you put
emphasis on whatever becomes a widely
accepted medium exchange will tend for
that reason to be adopted as well as the
basis for the unit of account is simply
more convenient that way charge people
in prices that are in terms of what you
expect to get paid now we all know that
federal reserve dollars much as we may
not like them or at least the way
they're managed our money because you
can use them for pretty much any
purchase in the country and plenty of
purchases outside for that matter the
carl menger explains to us how it is
that something can become a generally
accepted medium of exchange but minger
by that and that's money Mangrum
emphasizes this widespread or general
acceptability is the real key we've seen
that bitcoin is accepted in trade i'll
talk a little bit more about that but
it's certainly not it certainly doesn't
qualify as generally accepted menger
also has a theory about how things
become generally accepted in exchange
and and this theory to suggests the
problem with Bitcoin it's not only that
it isn't a widely accepted medium of
exchange but in according to the most
mangers theory it should never be
possible for it to become a medium of
exchange
meggers theory suggests that money grows
out of barter and it starts out with
people trying to figure out how can they
how can they barter more effectively by
trading what they have for something
that may be a little bit easier to fob
off for what they want well as people
start trying to do this of course they
start focusing on certain goods to trade
for which they can they hope trade again
for other goods they really want so you
get a kind of a horse race going and
eventually his certain goods seem to be
more successful as media of exchange one
or two or and eventually perhaps only
one become generally adopted for that
purpose purpose at which point you have
no longer got party you've got money the
problem is though that according to
conventional wisdom nobody's going to
think to trade what they have for
something that no one wants in order to
try to trade that again they're going to
look for things that already have trade
value for non non monetary reasons
things that have valued as jewelry for
example or ornament as cowrie shells
where for example and as of course the
precious metals where you nobody wants
digits until they can figure out
something to do with the digits and
otherwise you just have plain money now
once you get people using enough people
using something as a medium of exchange
more and more other people wants to use
it for that reason so if you can just
get this this this bandwagon going it
tends to be self reinforcing but that
too is a problem for any innovative new
would be currency because when you have
already a fully established generally
accepted medium of exchange a bandwagon
that everybody's pretty much on who
wants to jump on another empty bandwagon
so Bitcoin not only isn't really money
it shouldn't be possible for it to
become money but there's a prospect
because of in fact despite the
bitcoins have gotten a foothold as
exchange media it's interesting why they
should have done so given what I just
said and they're gaining ground so let's
talk about that it started out just as a
bunch of computer geeks playing around i
doubt that this japanese fellow ever
really existed i suspect it was a bunch
of people who looked about as japanese
as these guys one of them looks a little
bit like Sam and they were just plain
they were just playing around right and
and but eventually this little toy they
were playing around with this play money
if you like started to be perceived to
something that had some some virtues as
exchange outside of the little network
of players that started out doing this
and the next thing you know people are
finding it useful for well certain kinds
of transactions and but but of course
the whole point of mangers theory is
that if something gets adopted it all is
in exchange medium it becomes more
attractive for others to adopt it and
that seems to be what has happened
having gained a foothold surprisingly a
Bitcoin has managed to prosper since
then and now of course we have even
large important firms accepting Bitcoin
and the figure was mentioned by Garrick
that there are now some 75,000 merchants
I assume that's just in the US who
accepted I remember about three years
ago pointing out that there were a
thousand and saying I bet just there's
ten times as many in a year and then
sure enough it was ten thousand and that
was so that was two years ago or so and
here we are at 75,000 well you can see
what's what the trend is in principle
this could go very far we don't know of
course how far it will go so yes
bitcoins could conceivably become money
they could and they've gotten further
than many would have ever expected they
could do oh but there's a problem
if bitcoins were to become money that is
if they were to become a widely accepted
medium of exchange and and even more
importantly if they were to actually
displace dollars and we're just using
bitcoins and now we've got a Bitcoin
economy we've got prices expressed in
Bitcoin we don't to worry about the Fed
we've got a Bitcoin supply and that's
controlled well it's not controlled at
all it's predetermined that's got its
advantages and its disadvantages one of
the obvious disadvantages is again
something that was referred to by Garak
is that the price bounces around all the
time now of course here we're looking at
the exchange rate in terms of dollars
what we would care about in a Bitcoin
economy is the overall stability of the
purchasing power of bitcoins but if the
present stability or instability in
terms of dollars is any guide the stuff
could bounce around a lot more than
dollars themselves and could even lose
value over time perhaps more rapidly
than dollars if recent experiences to be
our guide now of course once bitcoins
widely accepted we should realize that
there will be an element of stability to
its to the demand for it that's simply
not present now since it's not yet money
and so it's a mistake to assume that the
stability of Bitcoin as money would
mirror or resemble the stability or
instability that it has today as an
aspiring money so let's not be uncommon
let's not over estimate or overstate the
potential instability of a Bitcoin
medium exchange but there's another
problem which is a longer-term problem
and it has to do with the algorithm that
determines the quantity of Bitcoin
output over time the algorithm
essentially raises mining costs
regardless of what mining technology and
effort is going on so that the total
amount of bitcoins produced in any
period is strictly predetermined and in
its predetermined according a schedule
this schedule that has it level off at
21 million coins within another I think
something like 20 years from now
more or less less than that perhaps
we've got about 13 or 14 million some
thinking like that so far so in short
the total maximum quantity of bitcoin
currency if it gets adopted as a general
meeting exchange or not is absolutely
fixed there can never be more now let's
compare that to something like the gold
standard okay the gold standard was not
a fixed quantity exchange me and what in
fact mining of gold went on all the time
in the gold standard air as it has done
since moreover the amount of mining
activity tended to increase with the
purchasing power of gold or with the or
opposite movements in the general price
level while on a gold standard that
meant that there was an automatic
tendency for more gold to be mined if
the purchasing power of money was
growing rapidly and that tended to
stable that per table eyes that
purchasing power over time and that's
why we had long run price level
stability under the gold standard with
some short run tendency for prices to
fall corrected in the long run by new
mining effort and discoveries Bitcoin
won't give us such a result it would be
expected instead to deliver much more
long-run deflation than the gold
standard and perhaps levels of deflation
that could be rather unpleasant remember
that i'm not an opponent of deflation
gradual deflation consistent with
productivity growth is something I've
advocated or at least defended at length
but here we're talking about a currency
that good in the long run produce more
deflation than that and harmful
deflation because it can't keep up with
the overall real demand for money as a
gold standard might banking could help
there's no reason why you couldn't have
Bitcoin based banking that would provide
another a set of substitutes for Bitcoin
but again that gold banking systems gold
the gold standard had of course
gold-based
he substitutes created by banks and yet
it was still desirable that the gold
supply should be able to grow and
augment the base of monetary gold of her
time again this standard wouldn't allow
it but now we come to another prospect
which is that in principle Bitcoin
technology and now I you notice i say
bitcoin rather than bitcoins can be used
to make a distinctly superior money
let's first step back and look at the
problems of the sorts of monies that
have been available to us in the past
well we've got fiat monies like the
dollar that can be arbitrarily
manipulated and are by a body of people
making discretionary decisions when they
do the wrong thing it can be very bad
news indeed yes the dollar is better
than plenty of other fiat currencies in
the world but it's not particularly
great when you're being told that two
percent inflation is just rock bottom
even though it means the value of money
is cut in half every 35 years or so
that's pretty bad and that's the best we
can expect things to expect to do in the
future we could do much worse indeed but
past commodity monies which have been
the only alternative so far they're not
perfect gold had virtues that I
mentioned in principle though it you
could have a major goal to Scott
discovery that could disrupt the
purchasing power of gold you could say
have changes the non-monetary demand and
so on by the way most critics of the
gold standard who mentioned these things
never bother to compare the actual
record of such shocks to gold's
purchasing power with the record of what
happens under fiat money when some
central banker shocks the supply of that
but never mind the truth is that past
commodity monies haven't been perfect
they are subject to the whims of nature
in the same way that fiat money is
subject to the whims of then well here's
the cool thing about Bitcoin
in principle the same sort of people who
came up with the original algorithm can
come up with another one with a supply
adjusts in a much more let's say macro
economically friendly way there's no
reason in principle while you can't have
a version of Bitcoin that preserves the
desirable features of the present one it
wouldn't be Bitcoin of course it would
be an alt coin of some sort but where
the total supply schedule not only
allows for long-run growth of the supply
but also can allow for feedback and in
response to say the number of
transactions and other measures of
spending that could give you a
relatively smooth spending schedule over
time and and thus have the supply
automatically adjust and adjust beyond
the power of anyone to manipulate it in
a macro economically desirable way in a
way consistent with long run monetary
stability it's perfectly technological
technologically possible I'm told so
that's good news some people sometimes I
talk about this being a doomsday machine
right the thing about Bitcoin technology
is you set up this algorithm and you're
done no one can ever manipulate it again
you can't turn it off you can't change
it you can't you're set with it and I've
heard people say well you know that's
that's terrible what if we have a
contingency well if you set the thing up
you can take into account the kinds of
contingencies that would really warrant
some change in the supply of money but
you're not making it so that anybody can
otherwise manipulate I think that's a
good thing I think it's sometimes good
to more or less you lash yourself to the
mast monetarily speaking and have a
money where nobody can mess around the
virtue of the gold standard was that
nobody could suddenly put some more gold
in the ground you know and change the
mining profits that way I had to say
something about him
you know is this key Krugman's running
obit corn you know it's just there's no
there's no foundation for the stuff it's
just digits for goodness sake there's no
foundation for fiat money but at least
with bitcoin we know they'll never beat
more than 21 million how can Krugman
assume that fiat dollars are there for
something we can rely on more in the
long run than than Bitcoin don't
understand that argument frankly ah but
alas I end on a negative note a problem
the cyber currency competition and I say
this is a big fan of the general idea of
currency competition I've spent most of
my career writing about it won't
necessarily favor the most stable
possible currency now I think in
principle we we want to see Bitcoin and
other such currencies compete freely
with established currencies for starters
we'd like to have a level level playing
field so that they can have a chance to
you know be chosen if people prefer them
we need to therefore watch out about
things like taxing Bitcoin as a
commodity and subjecting it therefore to
capital gains and all that it's a
reasonable decision if you assume
Bitcoin won't become money but it will
be prejudiced it prejudices things
against it against its coming becoming
so then of course we have all these
other potential cyber currency rivals to
Bitcoin that keep popping up and we want
them to be able to compete too but
here's the problem and it goes back to
Hayek's theory that Garrick also
mentioned Hayek assumes in the
nationalization of money which really is
a prescient work in light of bitcoin
bitcoin comes closest to resembling what
hike envisioned in that book when he
talked about pride fiat money she
actually imagined people issuing private
firms issuing fiat monies which is that
is monies that didn't consist of useful
commodities but managing them so that
they would maintain their value over
time now here's the catch hike assumed
the competition
on these different fiat currency issuers
would lead to those providing the state
most stable currencies and he had in
mind stability of purchasing power
winning out over the others that sounds
reasonable if you're talking to
economists because economists of course
would say most of them of all these
currencies here is the best one it's the
most stable the problem is that
consumers of currencies that it was
people choosing which currencies to
trade with aren't necessarily thinking
in macro economic terms not necessarily
choosing something because it has the
desirable property of maintaining its
purchasing power over time for example
just to stick to that criterion which we
can have issues with their other
criteria we might macro economically
prefer some of us but the problem is
hike never really established that
competition would lead to that result
and there's a very critical literature
that says for example in the case of
printing fiat money that one problem
would be in that case that it might be
optimal for producers to say they're
going to stabilize purchasing power and
then to just print tons of this stuff
and cheat their customers in the case
that we're talking about now though I
think there's a much more fundamental
problem which is if you and I are
deciding which of these cyber currencies
which should we try to trade with if
they're all equally tradable so far it
means doing making that decision means
making a decision perhaps to hold this
currency in your wealth portfolio for
some period of time it might not be very
long other things being equal what do
you prefer having a currency in your
wallet that appreciates depreciate
sourced a stable the answer is
appreciate and and so I don't think we
know that people would in fact favor
what economists might call the macro
economically stable choice rather than
going for what appreciates fastest as
long as it's sitting in their cyber
wallet
we have therefore no solid reason for
assuming that competition among cyber
currencies Bitcoin like currencies would
necessarily result in that currency
prevailing taking over that would be the
most stable well I've left on a problem
and neither will be happy I thank you
all very much for your attention one now
we're almost complete what we have to do
we have time for some questions and
there will be these two lovely ladies
over here I'll be walking around with a
microphone so if you'd wait till you get
the microphone and if you could say who
you're addressing the question too I
will let them hand the microphone to
somebody and they can go so let's have
and you know if you don't ask questions
we'll just start calling on people so
yeah thank you I'd like to take up the
challenge which which George has posed
at the end about how to make sure that
the the best currency wins I'm just
wondering you know maybe this is a
fantasy world or something like this
that the maybe I'm sure you put it this
is this is real fantasy I suppose that
the Fed could adopt Bitcoin rules or
that the Fed could adopt the rules you
could in fact you can put in a Taylor
rule for the growth of currencies or
something like this and in some sense
make a house you put it a sophisticated
autumn is a shin of monetary policy that
that would avoid or whatever problems of
discretion or whatever otherwise that
there might be is that something that
fits along with the schema Bitcoin or is
that something that's totally different
and doesn't doesn't connect to this
vision so I guess I'd addressed this
first to George and then maybe anybody
else who wants to come in yeah thank
thank you for that question it does
connect and you know we think of Hayek
we've I've said and Garrick you said
Hayek was rather prescient on Bitcoin
but there was another fellow as
prescient too in a way and that was
Milton Friedman because Friedman way
back was saying that the ideal
arrangement and one he favored in the
70s was that instead of having the fat
you should have the money supply
controlled by a computer that would just
spit out a certain amount of base money
every year and that would be that in
other words enforcing a strict monetary
rule and of course the idea is you have
this computer instead of an FOMC you
shut down the FOMC is a computer there
and the reason I put dr. strangelove up
there is because the idea is you you
have this computer and you don't no one
has the key or anything that access to
it that could reprogram it all right so
the the whole idea is that Bitcoin
technology is a way of having a the
freedmen computer solution but having it
be much more sophisticated in how
handle much more sophisticated possible
supply algorithms than Friedman himself
had in mind when he was writing at a
time when computers weren't very well
developed the paler rule of course is a
much different thing precisely because
as you note as long as you actually have
a FOMC responsible for implementing a
rule you don't have a reliable rule at
all that's why of course rules you're
used to talked about a fantasy world
right all talk of monetary rules insofar
as it's talk of rules to be implemented
by central bankers it's all fantasy
we've never seen any such thing and
that's because central bankers can't
help wanting to exercise discretion you
put a bunch of PhDs at a table even if
you put some bankers there to try to
rein them in they're going to want to
use their brains to do something you
know and and it's and it's not usually
going to be good which is what Friedman
taught us so so if you we won't get
central bankers therefore to say oh this
Bitcoin stuff is great let's just put
that in place of us but I think we
should be talking ourselves about how
that might not be a bad idea right if we
do believe that the talk of monetary
rules is any merit at all we should be
thinking about any technology that could
actually make rules such rules of
implementable and strictly enforceable
and in bitcoins one of those if Garrett
could like that just briefly I just
wanted to let you all know I'm actually
working on this and been thinking about
this for quite a while and have been
speaking with a number of central banks
around the world who are interested in
this idea who unlike the Federal Reserve
actually would have good reasons to
introduce a fully automated alternative
or parallel currency that kind of
leverages some of the Bitcoin technology
so we're going to be organizing a
meeting in 2015 to kind of explore the
theory behind this it's going to be very
sophisticated work that Garry Lou to
that's going to need to be done to to
manage kind of a flexible supply that
can do things like defend against
lative currency attacks etc but if
you're interested in this please get in
touch what is the difference between the
private key in your own password and
accessing you've been going account and
second quickly the question about how
the IRS is handling this they said
capital gains but is each individual
account going to have to be kept
separately like if I bought a cup of
carbon starbucks coffee do I have to
keep a record of that to calculate games
and lost our losses so I'll take the
second one first and just say talk to an
accountant or a lawyer I'm not a hundred
percent sure and as you guys are
probably all aware the IRS itself is
probably not sure either they don't know
how to interpret their own rules often
so in theory in theory you would have to
calculate the gains on pretty much every
transaction but I in practice I'm not
sure your first question is about the
difference in passwords and private keys
the private public key pair is are
related to each other you sort of have
to have both for the system to work
they're both essentially random strings
of numbers and letters the private key
itself gives you access to the bitcoins
on the blockchain by signing and having
other people verify it a password is
just a way to restrict other people from
accessing your data in a particular way
so you can use a private key without a
password we can use a private key with a
password the private key itself is just
a random string of data that correlates
to the public key oh yeah you were
looking at me with your IRS question I
don't know if you sense that my mother
works at the IRS
she's actually retiring next week but uh
the IRS has issued guidance you do have
to keep track of basis and each Bitcoin
you purchase and even a use of Bitcoin
for goods and services transaction is a
taxable event in the US that's not true
in other tax jurisdictions the UK has
ruled that you can use bitcoins for
goods and services transactions like
pounds and it's not taxable but in the
u.s. right now the rules are yes thank
you have a question for Sam you
mentioned at the beginning one of your
arguments is the Liberty aspect of this
this currency yet at the first part of
your demonstration you showed these
glass boxes which were very transparent
you immediately moved into something
that even for a person like me who's an
actuary was extremely untrained spirit
and algorithms and you know who's in
charge of what and who really founded
this thing you know Mount gox lost six
hundred million dollars where's the
transparency in that can you explain to
me why we're not just replacing one
tyrant with another in this process it's
a great question so yes the glass box
analogy means that this sort of the
blockchain this public ledger is
viewable by everyone in that sense you
don't necessarily have much financial
privacy but bitcoin is it's called
pseudonymous right anonymous is what
cash is right the cash in your guys's
wallet is anonymous no one knows how
much there is if you do transaction with
someone in cash no one else knows about
that except the person you're
transacting with that's anonymity in in
finance credit cards are the other way
totally identifiable completely hundred
percent bitcoins in the middle so all
these transactions are public except
your name is not attached to them it's
just sort of a again the public key is a
random string of letters and numbers so
even though all the transactions are out
there they're not necessarily tied to
your name so you have some amount of
financial privacy but your question is
transparency of maybe third parties this
is why it's important to re-emphasize
ownership of the private key is
ownership of Bitcoin itself if you give
third party your private key you no
longer effectively own those bitcoins
you have an IOU it is just like using a
bank
alright the money in the bank right now
is an argue from them you don't actually
have it right so what happened with
Mount gox mount Cox was the largest
Bitcoin exchange is that there were tens
of thousands of people who were willing
to put money into this exchange a
company operated in Japan and let them
own the private keys to their Bitcoin
for them well you can see why that's
potentially problematic because when the
company folded because of technical
problems on their own and not Bitcoin
everyone lost the private the probably
keys were lost everyone lost their money
so I don't recommend you let third
parties hold your private keys the point
is to hold the money yourself right do
we have one on this side we have one
more time for one more question so okay
we have one over here thanks that was an
excellent presentation my question is
taking this from the perspective that
pessimists are only pleasantly surprised
in life two things I was wondering about
first obviously this relies on
electricity and the whole planet isn't
uniformly electoral pride nor is it
consistently electrified power goes out
right here in Indiana periodically and
how does that impact your ability to
utilize this money or you want to call
currency at this point and then the
second thing is what about parts of the
world where the internet is not as open
and is restricted by the governments of
those nations and could that affect the
Commerce that one can participate in
with this type of Bitcoin currency so
all attempt to answer that quickly so on
the first part of my electricity yes
it's dependent on you know the
electrical grid and the Internet of
course itself as is pretty much all
financial systems today right I mean
your bank you know if it doesn't have
power you're not getting your money out
so it's it's not really distinct except
for cash right cash does and gold you
could say have those advantages moving
forward probably hopefully not going to
be a problem most hopefully we have
electrical grid in the internet moving
forward the places where it's restricted
is interesting one of course you know
China the Great Fire
that sort of stuff the people who use
Bitcoin and who build the coin are
typically pretty technologically
advanced and very find ways around that
essentially you may have heard of the
Tor network those kinds of things it's a
way to get around restrictions bitcoin
is going to be able to get around those
restrictions all right with that I'd
like to have you join me in thanking our
panel and we'll be back in a little bit
thank you so much that was really
fascinating and a lot of information
there are a lot of good information we
have a break you may exit through the
back or the side we have coffee out and
some treats for you to refresh yourself
please be back in here at ten fifteen
and I thank Gary I think Garrick and Sam
and George marvelous panel thank you
very much